uh i don't know if you guys have been
watching the show but we've been playing
actual voicemails from my father
occasionally he leaves me these really
funny voicemails it's very fun
especially for my dad he loves being
part of the show but here's something
new we're going to do is uh my father
isn't the only one who's been leaving
messages for old pity
so we've been doing voicemails for my
father but today we're doing a new
segment called voicemails from my
uncle larry
i just got your number from your brother
i i i don't know how i
i lost it
but jesus i'm so excited about this new
show
i i just hope and pray i'm to pray for
you i know you're going to knock them
dead
i'm so proud of you so
give me a call when you're busy
scheduled i know you're you're big
important
guy a celebrity now
but you can still call your uh
your uncle here in in in boston and uh
you know give me a little thrill with it
a personal uh
call to say hello you know
see if you can squeeze me in between you
know schmoozing with like
conan and
jimmy fallon and jimmy kimmel and
all the rest of them
all right nephew
all the best pal god love you
all of that
my uncle larry everybody i love you god
bless young larry